[Music]
how have you been enjoying the current
anime season
i actually find it quite strong i know
everyone's hyped for jiu jitsu kaizen
haiku and all of that but how about we
take a break and look ahead at the
wonderful season in front of us
after browsing through the chart some
time ago i can't say that it's an
exaggeration that i'm stoked for wants
to come during the winter 2021 season
before that why don't you share with
everyone what you're watching in the
current season
fill the comments section with your
favorites then regular watchers who
haven't done so yet
hit the subscribe button and let's get
going
well well well what do we have here and
it's a guy to kickstart the list of
course
so yeah the story goes like this demon
king and hero fight each other their
fight causes a huge explosion in the
classroom of a certain high school
boom dead protagonist reincarnated as
a spider yet our protagonist someone who
has the lowest reputation in class of
course
gets reincarnated not as an overpowered
character or a master of magic
but a spider what can such a lowly
creature do in this treacherous fantasy
world
turns out a lot actually especially if
you've got the willpower that our
protagonist has to survive and adapt now
i've probably said that one too many
times already but i enjoyed the story as
it had some moments where it felt like a
horror
series the closest comparison that i can
think of of the top of my head is slime
this is nowhere near slime levels of
comedy or parody with its overpowered
characters
why not continue the other world train
with the next entry the much awaited
log horizon season three
[Music]
yeah they made us wait for a while for
this one i actually lost hope for a
third season of log horizon a couple of
years back with all the issues from the
author and we know how the japanese
react to those nonetheless the seemingly
impossible became a reality when the
third season of long horizon got
announced after around half a decade
then more
twists in the real world are got this
postponed but the wait
is finally over log horizon will be
making its return in early 2021 and what
a story arc will get
it feels good to see shiroway and the
gang again and this time they get
heavily tangled with the round table
alliance
will an already shaky alliance crumble
in the face of pressure if you're up for
some more trapped in a video game
shenanigans with more focus on society
building instead of fighting
it's never too late to start watching
log horizon now starting from the first
season
it's definitely worth it
[Music]
we finally end with the isekai titles
with the next entry on the list
the second season of the quintessential
quintuplets
[Music]
quintessential quintuplets has been a
surprise i initially watched it for the
all-star voice actor cast
but i ended up enjoying it a lot more
than i expected i would it really helped
that the characters each have charm and
are really funny
and for a harem title like this you
don't really need a lot more
it may seem at first to be your standard
harem but quintessential quintuplets has
great character development
and the stark contrast in the
personalities of the quince really force
our protagonist to deal with them
differently
it's a nice mix that seems so generic
yet unique and enjoyable at the end of
the day i really wouldn't mind a second
season of this and i think it's a lot
more popular with other shows of the
same genre for a good reason
given the general reception with how the
manga ended and some of the speculation
regarding this season we might have the
story end in the second season i wonder
if they'll do an anime original ending
here with the fan's preferred winner
quintuplets was but a momentary reprieve
we take the plans to another world again
with mushoku tensei
haha you thought the asakai titles were
done didn't you fortunately or
unfortunately we're just getting started
with all the talk in the community about
this title how could we not
include mushoku tensei on the list did
you see how excited
some people mostly readers were when
this thing got announced for those
who've been in the light novel community
for a while
it wouldn't surprise me if you're quite
familiar with the story of rudius
greyrat
a 34 year old who hails from our boring
old world he retains his knowledge in a
second life driven not to repeat the
same mistakes that he did prior to his
date with trakun however there's one
rather undesirable trait that he prefers
not to let go of
his perversion and he dreams of making
moves on the best women in the world
having an isakai that acts as a more of
a coming-of-age story is quite rare
relatively speaking but given how
saturated the genre has become i
wouldn't be surprised to see in issachar
of pretty much every possible plot point
imaginable at this point a lot of people
praise his world building but whether
those good things would translate into
the anime format or not we're just going
to have to wait and see
my name dropping was a premonition and
the next show on our list is
slime season 2.
[Music]
you better be because the second season
of reincarnated as a slime is coming
your way initially scheduled to air in
fall
2020 it was the victim of the numerous
anime postponements given that 2020 has
been an outlier a weird year to say the
least but nothing can keep a good show
down and this second season is set to
hit our screens this january it's easy
to point at slime as a protagonist shows
off how overpowered he is and everyone
loves him for its show but i think this
time is quite the charismatic show in
its own right this allowed it to rise
above the pack amongst isakai titles
when it first aired a couple of years
back and with the first season done
it's time to start moving to the more
serious parts of the story all
signs point to this being the darkest
arc yet in slime's relatively
light-hearted run perhaps there'd be a
challenge that even the strongest
protagonists won't be able to solve and
that's not to mention the emotional
rollercoaster that we should be ready
for this season
rimaru makes his grand return this
january and you better be there when he
does
[Music]
we resume with not an isakai yep the
meme's dead
for now alright have some b stars then
[Music]
you know i have a confession to make i
initially dismissed b stars when i first
saw it it just didn't seem too much of
my thing even with all the accolades and
the good things being said about its
manga then before the first season aired
i read some of its manga and hey it's
actually a damn good series from pretty
much every angle yeah it seemed to be
anime zootopia at first glance but b
stars has thoroughly impressed me with
its themes related to prejudice and
self-discovery
it's also a lot darker than i expected
and while i strongly maintain that dark
doesn't automatically equate to good
it worked well for something like b
stars the first season was a sleeper hit
that kind of took the community by storm
when it aired and i can't wait to see
more in its second season stop sleeping
on b stars everyone
start catching up and i'm sure that
you'll end up not being able to wait for
the upcoming season 2 soon enough
next up on the list
not sure about you but i really like
these fluffy romantic comedy shows it's
a good change of pace isn't it the setup
of this series is a lot simpler than you
might think
basically two people with hidden sides
to themselves encounter each other and
fall for each other how will things work
out for the idol with socializing issues
and the otaku who's surprisingly gentle
despite having all those piercings and
bad boy markings it's been quite a while
since we've had one of these shows that
isn't a harem and i think the horimia
with its twists and genuinely
interesting developments deserves all
the hype that he gets from the fan base
next we take a look at dr stone's sequel
this list is becoming eerily close to
the most anticipated 2021 shows list i
put up some time ago
hey i can't help it the upcoming season
is just so strong when you take into
account hype and anticipation from the
fan base with all these sequels well
dr stowed is back and is bringing with
it what we all love from the series
science action exploration and
more science hell yeah the fan favorite
comes storming back with the
continuation of the stone walls arc and
it looks like we'll also make some
headway into knowing about the truth of
the world and the initial petrification
that changed everything one of the most
beloved shonen of 2019 makes its much
awaited return
i swear i'm not the only one excited to
see senku grace us with his presence
once again
is there any way we can fast forward to
january already it's only a little over
a month to go but the weight is just
killing me
coming up second is none other than the
continuation of re
zero's second season
they pulled a fast one on us gotta admit
it could they have picked a worse way to
end the first court of re-zero season
two than that
not bad in a legit bad way but it's one
of the biggest cliffhangers that we
could ever get as it revealed
a lot of the secrets behind the witches
and the truth behind one of the most
enigmatic characters this series has so
far
luckily the wait isn't too long and we
get to have our continuation this
january the suffering continues but as
we all know
a light at the end of the tunnel awaits
subaru after all these trials
will he finally be the hero that helps
amelia clear the trials and rescue
everyone from sanctuary probably but i
can't wait to see how he'll piece
together all the knowledge from his
revives to finally succeed in doing so
oh and let's not forget subaru also has
a mansion to save
whoa that sure is a lot to take in for
what's looking to be an exciting way to
cap off the current arc of one of the
decades most beloved isakais in a mirror
of a previous list
we have promised neverland season 2 at
the top of the list
right after re-zero
it's no surprise that one of the
standout shonen in the modern era has
the title of the most anticipated anime
locked up re-zero was hype but i think
that the general populace in 2020 had an
even stronger reception to promise
neverland and needless to say this is
the sequel
everyone wanted and got and it's funny
because whenever i talked about promise
neverland before i never failed to
mention how the anime ended on a decent
note
instead of a blatant cliffhanger ending
like a lot of titles
no game no life promised neverland
actually wrapped up in a way where you
can call it a day and just read the
manga afterwards nonetheless we'll be
seeing the continuation of the kids
journey and after escaping the hell that
is grace field house they now come face
to face with the open society of demons
the question of what lies in the world
beyond might be trite at this point but
in a series like promised neverland
it's a genuinely intriguing one i mean
aren't you curious as to what really
happened between mankind and demon kind
that was beyond the kids knowledge
leading to the whole farm system we
might get some hints to help us answer
those questions as the story moves on in
its exciting next chapter
so how does the winter 2021 season look
to you looking really good huh it's a
sequel galore so i might consider doing
another list soon with no sequels for
that stay tuned if you enjoyed watching
and want to have more content like this
make sure to browse through my channel
and subscribe if you haven't already
also you might want to check out my
other channel where i do video essays on
a lot of popular shows like attack on
titan
fate and sword art online mostly the
former well then that's gotta do it for
now looking forward to seeing you in the
next video
see you
you